hey leute ich habe er das ist ein katzen
live stream
spieltag freundlich war einfach mal ein
bisschen im internet unterwegs und habe
dabei die website explore punkt ort
entdeckt keine bezahlte werbung aber
einfach die beste website der welt wir
haben auf dieser web ist unfassbar viele
tier live streams wie beispielsweise
halt hier einfach babykatzen die hier so
ein bisschen sah es aus als hätte sich
manchmal katze erschrocken dass ich dann
mit meiner maus drauf gegangen werden
jetzt geht's wieder schlafen kommen wir
trauen ihm ein bisschen hier
der wirft dieser website allerdings
nicht nur irgendwelche langweiligen
süßen livestreams von irgendwelchen
katzen die gerade bei ihrer muttermilch
saugen nero löwen
das ist papa löwe papa löwe verbuddelt
gerade seine scheiße könnte mal wieder
töten oder so das ist doch immer papa
löwe papa löwe beobachtet mama papa löwe
macht das neidisch dass mama löwe mit
einer anderen frau unterwegs ist ist man
mal will es bis zum nächsten live stream
das ist ingrid ingrid hat er seit drei
wochen nichts zu essen da wird es auch
erstmal krieg kennt wir scheißen auf
ingrid und schauen uns mal das ja an
und was geht
bernd r
die haben wir interessantes leben
ja
werden andere farbe ein paar sekunden
später
stellt euch vor
ihr seid im meer und ihr könnt hier
schwimmen wo ihr wollt und ihr schwimmt
die ganze zeit mit 0,3 km h im kreis ja
wirklich sorgen da muss ich ganz klar
sagen ihr habt eine ziemlich lang
die schwere mit 0
am kreis und ich gucke ihnen dabei zu
also mein leben ist auch nicht viel
spannender
also ich würde sagen dass hier
eigentlich ein schild grad aber
irgendwie nicht da der vogel schiller
gerade nicht in seiner haut ist würde
ich sagen schauen wir uns zebras verlust
sich das zebras nach dem zebrastreifen
benannt wurden alle deine schnauze climb
es so ist dass das gerät
[Musik]
in telephone
ein freund ich bin einfach gerade einmal
schockiert weil ich habe noch nie
jemanden gesehen der aus langem rüssel
als nächstes wird mir hier an gezeigt
dass wir ein papa eine reine ich könnte
er gibt ihm die ganze zeit bank weiter
sage jetzt haut er ab jetzt kommt noch
eine noch eine
also fische sind wirklich somit das
langweiligste hi
ich dachte ein stinknormales aquarium
auf einmal herum decker
was ich könnte den ganzen tag auf dieser
website hängen das haben wir nie
schaffen
scharfe welches möglich von denen am
liebsten
also wenn ich mal jetzt aussuchen dürfte
würde ich das nehmen die ziemlich
schäbig aus dass schaaf ich bin auch
scharf
also sonne spannenden content wie wie
hier auf meinem kanal selten
wer würde ich mal ganz schnell auf
abonnieren klicken
wo sind hier die tiere also sollen wir
angeblich seelöwen beobachten können
wahrscheinlich sieht man hier auch
wieder
unter oh okay
das stimmt nicht alles in italien
ja ja ja es ist die einordnung man
schaltet man einmal hier nicht nur ein
bisschen nur ein bisschen weihnachten ja
habe ich dreimal
doch natürlich komme erst korrekt er
sagt gar nichts
ob sie auch die auch jetzt komme halt
dein maul youtuber bringen high class
session raus spielt im film mit drin
selber kranke dokumentation
ich unterhalte mich mit seelöwen mini
mehr hören können
jetzt kratzt an der stelle würde ich und
diese unfassbar süßen labradorwelpen
dass an der stelle werden wir auf jeden
fall das heutige video zu beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
das gern einen download unter dem video
da wenn ihr bock auf mehr locker
reagiert auf tier livestream videos hat
dann der hat glaube ich niemand
er ist auch drauf und dran
[Musik]